hi I'd like to answer the question from
Brian in response to what keeps me
motivated I'm Stephanie and I am from
California in the United States I am
motivated by all the potential that our
future use hers I think that there is a
generation out there that is so
technically savvy so passionate about
sustainability and can really make a
difference in this world so that keeps
me motivated and the reason for that
motivation as well as my children you
represent our future and I know that the
future is in your hands and that you're
going to make the right decisions so
that we can have a world that's here for
generations to come do a lot for them